a growing concern around the world about
the covet variant omicron it's a new
strain first detected in south africa
and it's now spreading there quickly
it's also been reported in at least 14
countries including our neighbor to the
north canada
starting today the u.s is imposing
travel restrictions from south africa
and seven other countries in that region
while scientists work to understand this
new variant and for more on what we
understand right now we are joined by
president biden's chief medical advisor
that is dr anthony fauci dr fauci good
morning for most of us we had the most
normal thanksgiving since 2019. a lot of
us looking forward to the most normal
end of year celebrations christmas new
year's since 2019 now we have this new
variant why might it be a problem for us
and when will we know
well it's going to take a little bit
maybe a couple of weeks to get a real
good handle on it the thing that we do
know
that is concerning
is that there has been this
identification
in south africa and uh it is having a
degree of what we call mutations around
that part of the virus
we call the spike protein
that is responsible for the binding of
the virus to cells in your body which
suggests
that this would be more transmissible
and also suggest that it might evade
some of the immune parameters that we
have such as monoclonal antibodies and
convalescent plasma
as well as perhaps antibodies that are
induced
by vaccines when you look at it
clinically it appears from what we're
observing with our south african
colleagues who've been extremely
cooperative and helpful to us to
understand this it appears to be
spreading very readily in that it has a
transmission
advantage the things that we don't know
right now
is whether the people who do get
infected have a severe reform of a
disease or whether it's a light disease
or somewhat the same as delta so dr
fausch when you talk about a couple
weeks one and a half weeks we're heading
into the christmas end of year period uh
and people heard you uh yesterday say
it's too soon to tell whether we'll need
additional restrictions maybe even
lockdowns that's an upsetting word just
on its face what are the benchmarks
specifically if you could that you're
looking at that will guide your view on
whether we need to hunker down for the
holidays
well first of all let's not be talking
about lockdowns when people are asking
me about different things lockdowns is
not considered right now we don't have
this in this country what we should be
doing it likely will come tony it almost
certainly will because it's one of those
viruses that when you have a high degree
of transmissibility
to it it ultimately is going to get to
you the reason
we had the restriction on travel was to
give us time to first understand it
better and second to just intensify the
things that we are already doing
so nothing different i mean get
vaccinated for those who are
unvaccinated absolutely get boosted if
in fact you've already been vaccinated i
don't know how many more times you can
say that dr faucia you said it really is
ours to control at this point you got to
get the boosters you have to get the
vaccine let's just start with that but i
want to point out about south africa
they're very upset saying they're being
penalized they raised the alarm for all
of us in a way to help us to sound the
alarm and now they say they're being
penalized with the travel ban do you
think these travel bans are effective
well they certainly are not going to be
effective in keeping out this virus for
a prolonged period of time the reason
you do a travel ban is not that you
think naively that you're going to keep
it out but it buys you a couple of weeks
because if you can keep things out
in in in force for a couple of weeks you
can do a lot of things you know people
are very worried very scared some people
are saying use the word freaking out
should we should we be
no
no no gail we should not be freaking out
we should be doing the things that we
know
work when you're dealing with a pandemic
virus it's not the time to panic we
should be concerned and our concern
should spur us to do the things that we
know work
so rather than as you say freaking out
and rather than panicking just do the
right thing
yeah i don't know how many more times we
can say it but that's why we keep having
you on dr anthony fauci thank you so
much for your time
good to be with you thank you for having
me